did you ever find out who this ghost
Reddit guy is Ghost Reddit guys the guy
on what's the Reddit guy you were
supposed to be talking to is it going oh
oh um guilty guilty not ghosts I do not
know how guilty is to this day Jesus
now yeah and that was in a Discord
server oh see all this [__] is bro
[__] yeah yeah I always thought
Discord I was on Discord once and it was
because I'm a part of the I talked about
this I was on there's like this flip
group where you could they like tell you
what to buy and what you could flip it
for right right and it was I had to
download Discord and I then I guess it's
for gaming and [__] I guess there's all
different kinds of [__] yeah yeah
discord's good it's um you build a
community very valuable tool like is
there a bootleg Kev Reddit Community or
I don't want that [__] I feel you don't
make one we're good yeah
we're good buddy I learned I learned a
lot though and I'm grateful for it and
you know have you talked to Adam since
I have not spoken to Adam since the the
morning after
that all went down because I was kind of
like I wasn't even really 100 sure if
you got fired yeah even though I was
like it was still yeah but it was like
you just went off what you saw on that
stream it could be like open-ended it
was it was done out it was done out of
passion like let me see if there's any
reasoning with this guy right in the
morning sometimes people feel a little
bit different you know I send them a
text
um he was just kind of like hey you know
that's it but he what he did say was I'm
not gonna be bad-mouthing you or
slandering you any more and I was like
okay cool neither will I then proceeded
to call me a snake multiple times
um on several different podcasts and um
talk down on me so it's kind of like you
know I don't have any hate in my heart
towards him but it's I'm a little
confused by that what about Josh
uh Josh and I have texted on
about business a couple times but like I
need my last paycheck that's kind of
like but that's essentially like the end
of you know and I'm cool Josh I have no
problem with ultimately and um
so at the end of the days you know we we
all straight I still talk to A.D I still
talk to Tyrell house phone everybody
um they'll be appearing on my pod and
occasionally I might make some
appearances over there okay have you I
know you've just talked to smack this
morning I know you've been doing your
um I saw
who's the white guy you're on camera
with
on um it's a YouTube channel what's that
YouTube channel I'll ruin your day yeah
yeah okay so how like have you already
started your your actual I have my own
individual Channel That's lush world
yeah no so lush world is actually
because here's the thing that channel
that ruined your day channel is
something that I've been active in
actively a part of building since like
2015. so you already were a part of that
channel yeah yeah okay you know and
helped build a lot of the subs up right
and then when I you know had a
discussion with him is this is going to
be my home on YouTube for curating
content since there's already an
audience built in business-wise him and
I have an understanding and um so I
consider that channel as much mine as
anybody else's okay so then that's where
the lush world stuff's going yeah Lush
rolls over there there's the GTX channel
for battles um there's I have my own
channel for music so yeah are you still
gonna make music I'm I'm always gonna
make music that's like a passion thing
that's just a part of who I am right you
know what I mean like I got my
distribution deal with the my label with
John Urbano and Marissa Urbano called um
snow cone records which is uh we we
under Sony Orchard so like you know but
it's not paying the bills but
occasionally I'll get a placement and
it'll pop up like I just got a placement
in the show like you would do it for
free so I would always do it I'll do it
for free if I recently got a placement
in a a film called sick which is on the
peacock Network so you know get a little
bag here and there and when you got your
teeth done yeah
did you do it here or did you go to a
different country I didn't hear oh you
did yeah yeah yeah and these are
actually Temporaries for people who
don't know because are you are you doing
the implants do yeah these These are so
right now is a bridge I have a bridge on
top and a bridge on the bottom it's not
like Dentures I can't tell you you're
gonna get like full implants right yeah
yeah and so you're not even getting
veneers no no no no no no real boys yeah
yeah I have no teeth left on the top or
the bottom in between my canines they
cemented a bridge in so temporary that's
there and um I'll just tell you you're
gonna be out for a while I'll tell you
this little bootleg Kev the [__]
quotient is through the roof good for
you man knocking them down there I'm
glad to hear it I'm knocking them down
where are you finding them read it they
finding me they finding me it's crazy
like I I don't know I was about to say
Jesus Christ we gotta get this Velcro
you got to get it cemented like my damn
teeth for sure I was gonna say I always
uh what a note are no jumper groupies or
or battle rap groupies are they like
what kind of T because I always say the
ugliest groupies in the world are
Juggalos yeah yeah like icps groupies
God bless them just talk about [__]
speaking of meth Jesus Christ yeah I'm
not trying to have an orgy at the
Gathering no disrespect to the my
Juggalos you feel yeah shout out to I
love y'all
have you been to the Gathering I have
not I would love to go to the Gathering
I heard there's a drug tent yeah or no
there's a drug bridge I believe it and
then there's like a TP where there's
just a [__] in there you gang the orgy
the orgy 10. what's that person I like
welfare Bumblebee tuna child molestation
yeah like a kind of a baggy of all that
yeah 27 year old chicken there got
[__] by our uncle and her brother at
once and now she's getting [__] by now
she's got her uncle and Ratchet man
tattooed on her neck right but I would
say there's there's [__] second grade
teachers in this world right now with
Hatchet Man tattooed on their body you
know that's actually considered a gang
in various right yeah and there's like
in certain States like Utah
foreigners but the in Utah in Utah there
was some Juggalo wound up killing a
serrano and now there's a [__] green
light on the jungle in the Utah
Penitentiary system for any body with
the hatchet man tag things so I've been
told so the South cider's got beef with
the Juggalos in Utah yes and I don't
know if that's still a thing but this
was yeah that's interesting yeah what
are the Mormons and you can uh they're
Juggalo Mormons or South side Mormons I
don't know but and just to make it clear
this is not something that I'm bringing
to the internet this is something that's
already known if you you know tap into
different places